Tradutor: Leonardo Silva
Revisor: Custodio Marcelino
A primeira vez que eu vi um coração
na bancada do laboratório
de anatomia da faculdade,
eu fiquei absolutamente impressionada.
O coração é um músculo robusto,
capaz de bater 2,5 bilhões de vezes
ao longo da vida de uma pessoa.
Desde o começo da faculdade,
uma das primeiras coisas
que a gente aprende
é que um coração normal bate
de 60 a 100 vezes por minuto
e que qualquer alteração nisso
é sinal de que alguma coisa está errada.
Um coração que bate
mais rápido, por exemplo,
pode ser decorrência
de um sangramento, de uma infecção
ou até mesmo de a gente
estar abrindo o TEDxSãoPaulo.
(Risos)
Felizmente, hoje,
a gente tem várias formas
de investigar um coração
que bate diferente do normal.
Só que a medicina persiste
ainda com um problema,
e esse problema é o fato
de a gente tratar as pessoas
de acordo com o que funciona
pra maioria delas,
não de acordo com aquilo
que funciona pra cada uma,
com o que seria ideal pra cada uma.
Só que raramente a gente pensa
no que é essa maioria.
Eu vou explicar mais ou menos
o que é essa maioria.
A gente, médico,
quando vai tratar um paciente,
a gente se baseia numa série de critérios
chamados de medicina baseada em evidência.
São eles que mostram
pra gente, por exemplo,
quais são os estudos científicos
que mais têm peso
pra definir o que é
que funciona pra maioria.
Só que raramente a gente se pergunta
o que é essa maioria, né?
E eu fui atrás disso.
Eu descobri um estudo do FDA,
que é a agência que regula a liberação
de medicamentos novos nos EUA,
que mostrava um perfil
de todos os participantes,
de todos os pacientes
que participaram de estudos
pra liberar novas drogas no mundo,
e eu achei dois problemas nele.
Um é que só 1% da população
participa desses estudos,
e o segundo é que o que
a gente chama de maioria
na verdade corresponde a homens, brancos,
relativamente jovens,
com menos de 65 anos,
e americanos.
Ou seja,
o que a gente chama de maioria não reflete
a diversidade da nossa população.
A gente está aqui, em 2018,
falando no TEDx do futuro da saúde.
Só que a medicina é ainda mais primitiva
do que a gente gosta de admitir.
A gente fala tanto
em medicina de precisão,
mas o que a gente faz hoje em dia
é medicina de imprecisão.
OK, eu vim trazer
algumas verdades pra vocês,
mas eu não tenho só notícias ruins.
Como o Cazé falou,
eu sou médica intensivista.
Pra quem não sabe,
o intensivista é o médico da UTI,
é aquele médico
especializado em doentes graves
ou que têm grandes chances
de se tornarem graves.
Sim, tem gente que escolhe isso
pra própria vida,
mas, além disso, eu sou uma pessoa
absolutamente apaixonada
pela união entre tecnologia e saúde,
e eu acredito que isso tem o potencial
pra ajudar tanto médicos como pacientes
a entregar uma saúde melhor pras pessoas.
E como isso acontece?
Eu vou explicar pra vocês,
mas, pra explicar isso,
a gente precisa entender o que está
acontecendo no mundo atualmente.
E a gente vive um momento único
na história da humanidade. Por quê?
Porque, com os dispositivos
digitais que a gente tem -
os computadores, os tablets,
os smartphones, os relógios inteligentes -
e com as redes sociais,
a gente nunca gerou
tanta informação no mundo.
Pra vocês terem uma ideia,
90% de toda informação
que existe hoje no mundo,
de todos os dados que existem,
foram criados nos últimos dois anos.
Em saúde, isso é ainda mais pronunciado.
A gente vive numa era
em que, querendo ou não,
a gente nunca está offline,
a gente está gerando dados
o tempo inteiro.
Pra vocês conseguirem
imaginar a magnitude disso,
uma pessoa saudável ao longo da vida dela,
se a gente juntar toda
a informação de saúde que ela gera,
isso é o equivalente a 300 milhões
de livros cheios de conteúdo em saúde.
Se a gente pega toda essa informação
e coloca dentro de tablets
e empilha esses tablets,
a pilha que a gente consegue
tem um tamanho
que é um terço da distância
da Terra até a Lua.
Só que isso é quanto
a gente consegue analisar
de toda essa informação hoje em dia
com as ferramentas que a gente possui.
É 0,5%.
Agora, imagina o quanto de informação
que a gente não está perdendo
nesses 99,5% que a gente
está deixando de lado.
São informações absolutamente válidas,
que poderiam mostrar
pra gente, por exemplo,
como melhorar a qualidade
de vida das pessoas,
reduzir mortes evitáveis, prever epidemias
e, por que não, até curar doenças.
Só que aqui a gente chega
num segundo desafio:
quem vai analisar
essa quantidade de dados todos?
É o médico?
Na verdade, a gente já vive um tsunami
de informação só pra se manter atualizado.
Tem estudos que mostram
que, pra um especialista médico
se manter em dia
com absolutamente tudo que é publicado
de estudo científico na área dele,
seria necessário estudar
167 horas por semana.
São mais que 20 horas por dia.
É impraticável.
Na verdade, o nosso cérebro mesmo
já não é máquina suficiente
pra processar essa quantidade
de informação toda,
e muito menos os sistemas
de computação tradicional.
Por quê? Porque eles fazem só aquilo
que eles foram programados pra fazer.
Eles não trazem novidades,
eles não trazem hipóteses que ajudem
a gente a resolver problemas.
Daí, a gente pensa: “O que é
que poderia resolver esse problema?”
A primeira coisa que vem em mente são
robôs dotados de inteligência artificial,
mas a segunda coisa
que vem em mente é isso aqui:
são robôs dizimando populações inteiras
que foram inocentes
o suficiente pra confiar neles.
E como um médico trabalha
com inteligência artificial?
É se tornando um robô?
Felizmente, não.
Felizmente, isso tudo
está limitado às telas do cinema
e aos livros de ficção científica.
A inteligência artificial e os robôs
nunca vão substituir o médico,
muito menos dizimar a humanidade.
Na verdade, a gente precisa parar um pouco
de ter medo da inteligência artificial
e entender melhor o que é que ela é.
A inteligência artificial nada mais é
que uma série de ferramentas
que permitem que a nossa
inteligência seja aumentada.
Ela é a terceira era da computação.
É a era que vai permitir
que a gente saia daqueles sistemas
que fazem só aquilo que eles foram
programados pra fazer
e comece a receber esse mundo
todo de informação,
organizar toda essa informação,
ver o que tem lá no meio,
interagir com a gente
de forma mais natural
e trazer hipóteses
pra gente resolver problemas,
ficando mais inteligentes
cada vez que a gente usa eles.
Em saúde, isso tem um potencial gigante
porque isso pode ajudar a gente
a reduzir burocracia,
fazer diagnósticos mais precisos
e trazer tratamentos que tenham mais
chances realmente de ajudar as pessoas.
E foi um pouco disso que me motivou.
Se, até 2015, eu trabalhava
de 80 a 100 horas
em três UTIs de diferentes hospitais
daqui de São Paulo,
hoje em dia eu divido
o tempo fazendo isso,
mas também trabalhando
numa grande empresa de tecnologia,
desenvolvendo projetos
que ajudem a gente a explorar
como a inteligência artificial
pode ajudar médicos e pacientes
a entregar uma saúde melhor pras pessoas.
E eu vou dar alguns exemplos
do que já é possível pra vocês.
Eu começo pela oncologia,
a especialidade que trata o câncer.
A oncologia é uma das especialidades
em que é mais difícil
se manter atualizado.
Cerca de 75 mil artigos
são publicados por ano,
que o oncologista tem que saber,
com medicações novas,
novos regimes de tratamento.
Hoje em dia, já é possível
que médicos oncologistas,
no momento da consulta,
cruzem os dados do paciente deles
com toda a literatura
científica disponível
e isso traga, de forma ranqueada,
os tratamentos que têm mais chance
de dar certo pra cada um desses pacientes,
em vez de o que funciona
pra maioria das pessoas.
Isso tem sido utilizado
desde em hospitais de ponta nos EUA
até em países como a Índia.
A Índia tem mil oncologistas
pra uma população
de 1,4 bilhões de pacientes.
Muitos desses pacientes,
ao ter o diagnóstico,
nem tinham a chance de conseguir chegar
num centro de tratamento de oncologia.
Muitos, infelizmente,
acabavam morrendo antes disso.
Então, o que a inteligência
artificial tem feito
é permitido que médicos mais generalistas
consigam adiantar esse processo
e começar o tratamento desses pacientes,
pra que eles tenham mais esperança
e consigam ter o tempo, inclusive,
de chegar num oncologista
que vá dar continuidade
ao tratamento deles.
No sequenciamento genético,
já é possível utilizar
a inteligência artificial também.
A gente consegue hoje em dia
usar esse tipo de ferramenta
pra ler, por exemplo,
o resultado do sequenciamento genético
de uma pessoa com câncer,
e com isso detectar e ranquear
as mutações mais relevantes dessa pessoa,
cruzar com a literatura
e procurar os tratamentos
específicos pra essa mutação.
Aqui também a gente sai do modelo atual
que a gente tem de tratar o câncer,
que é tratar pelo tipo
de órgão que ele acomete -
um câncer de mama, um câncer gástrico
e um câncer de próstata -
e passa a tratar com o que funciona
pro câncer daquela pessoa,
pra mutação daquela pessoa.
Humanos conseguem fazer
essa análise também,
mas, pra analisar o sequenciamento
genético de uma pessoa,
são necessárias cerca de 160 horas.
Isso é quase uma semana.
Com a inteligência artificial,
esse tempo cai pra dez minutos.
O primeiro caso de sucesso
de uso da inteligência artificial
pro sequenciamento genético
aconteceu no Japão.
Num hospital da Universidade de Tóquio
existia uma paciente com leucemia
que já tinha passado por três
regimes de tratamento sem sucesso,
que eram os que funcionavam pra maioria.
Só que ela não era a maioria.
Daí, os médicos de lá resolveram testar:
"Vamos colocar o dado
do sequenciamento dessa paciente
pra inteligência artificial ler
e analisar junto com a gente".
E eles chegaram a descobrir
que ela tinha uma mutação rara
pra qual existia um tratamento
que não tinha sido tentado ainda,
e hoje em dia essa paciente
está se recuperando.
Outro exemplo é o diabetes.
Milhares de pacientes com diabetes
doaram os dados dos medidores
de glicose e de açúcar do sangue deles
pra serem interpretados por meio
de uma solução de inteligência artificial.
Isso permitiu chegar num algoritmo
que prevê, com três horas de antecedência,
quando essa pessoa vai ter hipoglicemia.
A hipoglicemia é aquela queda
de açúcar no sangue
que é superperigosa
pros pacientes com diabetes.
E, a partir do momento
em que o sistema detecta isso,
ele mesmo já dispara mensagens
pro smartphone da pessoa,
avisando que isso vai acontecer
e com medidas que ela pode tomar
pra evitar que isso aconteça.
Bom, os exemplos que eu posso
dar pra vocês são vários
do que está acontecendo hoje em dia.
Só que os pacientes, eu, vocês, todos nós,
a gente tem uma oportunidade
única nesse momento
porque a gente tem esse poder
computacional nos nossos bolsos,
por meio dos celulares, dos smartphones.
Nesse momento, a gente tem a oportunidade
de começar a ser mais ativo
em relação à nossa saúde.
Isso pode começar de várias formas:
desde a gente exigindo ter acesso
ao nosso prontuário
nos médicos e instituições
pelas quais a gente passa
pra que a gente também seja dono
desses dados e não só eles,
até transformar os aplicativos que ensinam
mais sobre a nossa saúde em nossos aliados
pra gente entender quantos passos
a gente dá, como a gente dorme,
o que a gente escolhe comer
e como isso impacta a nossa saúde.
A ideia aqui é que, a partir do momento
em que a gente é dono dos nossos dados,
a gente pode decidir o que fazer com eles.
É mais ou menos o que a gente faz no Waze,
em que a gente compartilha
os dados do nosso trajeto
e, em contrapartida, a gente recebe
quanto tempo a gente vai ter no trânsito,
quais obstáculos a gente vai ter
no caminho, como evitá-los
e como ter um caminho melhor
pra gente se locomover.
Se a gente faz isso na saúde,
compartilhando os nossos dados,
a gente começa a entender
que tipos de tratamentos e medidas
funcionam pra cada pessoa,
em cada bairro,
em cada cidade, em cada país
e no mundo, na verdade.
Uma das coisas mais humanas que existem,
quando a gente pensa,
é doar órgãos pra uma pessoa
em necessidade.
Eu acredito num futuro
em que a gente não vai só doar órgãos,
mas vai ser possível
a gente doar dados também,
porque, daí, em vez de ajudar
uma pessoa por vez,
a gente consegue ajudar várias
e a gente consegue garantir
que cada vez mais corações consigam
bater aqueles 2,5 bilhões de vezes
que eles nasceram pra bater.
Muito obrigada.
(Aplausos)